Україні потрібна фінансова допомога Заходу.
А Заходу - партнер, який виконує обіцянки.
Якщо Київ і надалі не триматиме свого слова,
ситуація, подібна до призупинення торік виплати
600 мільйонів євро допомоги ЄС,
повторюватиметься. На виконання яких обіцянок
Порошенка досі чекає Захід?
Міжнародний валютний фонд різко розкритикував
президентський законопроект
про Антикорупційний суд. У МВФ стверджують,
що цей документ не дозволить створити суд,
який користувався б довірою як в Україні, так і
на Заході. У ньому порушено зобов’язання
перед МВФ та не дотримано рекомендацій
Венеціанської комісії. Насамперед те,
як формуватиметься новий суд.
Представники міжнародних донорів України хочуть
мати право блокувати призначення
недоброчесних суддів. Захід побоюється, що
цей орган може стати імітацією боротьби з корупцією.
Брюссель розчарований також спробами
української влади взяти під контроль діяльність
Національного антикорупційного бюро.
Євродепутати, серед яких і впливова представниця
ФРН Ребекка Гармс, називають атаки на НАБУ
"безпрецедентними". Перш за все це намагання
наприкінці минулого року протягнути в парламенті
законопроект, який надав би Верховній Раді
і президенту широкі права для звільнення голів
антикорупційних відомств. Лише після тиску з ЄС
цей законопроект зняли з порядку денного, але
не відкликали повністю. Європейці побоюються, що
документ може повернутися в сесійну залу і бути
"під шумок" проголосований.
Починаючи з цього року,
представники громадських об’єднань, які
займаються антикорупційною боротьбою,
також повинні звітувати про свої статки
і заповнювати е-декларації. Порошенко обіцяв
виправити, за його словами, "нашу спільну помилку",
але так нічого і не зробив. У Брюсселі та Вашингтоні
не приховують свого роздратування і зазначають,
що мета закону - контролювати недоброчесних
чиновників, а не чинити тиск на борців з корупцією.
Верховна Рада наприкінці минулого року ухвалила
закон про реформу аудиторської діяльності,
щоб привести українське законодавство
у відповідність до стандартів Євросоюзу.
Однак закон набуде чинності аж у жовтні.
Така затримка заважає виконанню Угоди
про асоціацію з ЄС. І Порошенко, і Верховна Рада
знають про це, але гальмують набуття чинності
документа. ЄС закликав невідкладно ввести в дію
цей закон, мета якого - відновити довіру
до українських аудиторів. Без цього не варто чекати
на європейські інвестиції.